[Music]
this is you welcome with Marcel argüello
my guests today are the amazing Nico
Santos you know I'm from superstore
season premieres September 26 we also
have Moe Welch here great book how to
die alone you've seen her on Conan as
well
she's they're both amazing comedians and
they're their friends and I'm excited to
have them here how you guys doing today
good I need coffee on heroin yeah you
know some heroin you're welcome
who gets it yeah now how are you I don't
need coffee yeah that's yeah Moe's
currently pregnant yeah does that [ __ ]
with your sleep it does yeah like every
half hour to wake up and pee oh yeah
it's horrible
because you're on superstore I feel like
and I know for a fact cuz I saw it in
Tempe people have these expectations
that you're a family-friendly comedian
yeah that is you know it was an
interesting thing that I never really
thought because that was like one of the
first headlining weekends I've had
because I've been just so busy right
right doing the performing the show
right so when I did that weekend I was
surprised at how the audience really
sort of like was expecting me to be sort
of more clean-cut like our show yeah
Norah show isn't really that I know you
know what I just started watching it and
I was like there so like I know no
offense Nico my mother has stopped
watching it because I think it's too
many sex jokes in your windows in our
show it's barely they're not even
innuendos necessarily clean show but I
get people all the time II like the
watch just show with my entire family
yeah it's so nice to have a shut up we
can watch as a family I'm like you
should not be watching my mom stop
watching it cuz my nephew was she was
like this is inappropriate for him
yeah so I think people have that
expectation and you know we're out and
and opening my act and and I do talk
about like my life and yeah sexual stuff
yeah everything squirrels I leave every
straight guy , can talk about like oh I
know woman and why couldn't I talk about
Sunday I agree oh you know yeah gotcha
nico live in a city near yea big Felisa
join your family mo do you because you
were very strict presenting had any
people that come at you like oh I wasn't
expecting what are you were cuz
sometimes I'll just post a picture of
you to promote your weekend and people
like L anyway tickets and they're just
like oh my god dude I mean do you
experience to me what I get a lot which
is crazy like I get messages from men
who were like in their 60s and they'll
be like are you doing darlin you ever
come in through Peoria let me buy a
steak dinner and like it'll be like I
saw you like I would saw you open for
so-and-so or whatever and I'm like did
you watch my act because like people
will come up after and they're like wait
is that gay stuff real I'm like it is so
my boy I'm like do you think that I was
like how should I get ahead in the end
of yes what if like I to offer any men
in the industry like that's a great way
to get ahead I get asked that too if I
really am gay like when I went on the
road I'm just like why would I make this
up
like that's not a you know like
especially I mean now it's a different
story but like being LGBT is yeah some
more accepted in the industry but like
when I study comedy there was not an
advantage and it's just not something
you know like I'm very you know I'm very
femme leaning so it's just like I know
it's funny when they like no no that's
not that's not real like so now in my
act I'll usually say like like after I
do it's like some gay jokes and I'll be
like that's obviously a joke I'm not gay
I mean those are all jokes I'm just
trying to like I need a brand like
I know
stop being less stupid if you're an
audience member yeah have fun
hashtag believe gays I want to talk
about the Equal Pay discussion that has
been brought back to the surface
everything always does but when the u.s.
women's national soccer team won which
is incredible but as we all know they
don't make I mean not even half as much
as the men it's really disgraceful how
much they make it's crazy yeah think
about Megan Rapinoe I think about all
the footage everyone was posting about
afterwards and they were like genuinely
having a great time and does money is
money a motivator for a lot of us who
it's like we pursue something and you
know you're not gonna get paid the same
so you end up pursuing the things that
you really love well I mean money always
affects everything everything you know
right I mean like in and and when you
get to a level where you're lucky enough
to be working in the field that you love
you know you should be paid grant but
until then then what like what do we do
what are we doing to supplement are we
supplementing with income are we
supplementing with happiness it's like
that's the other reason someone like
Megan Rapinoe can go on and talk hell a
[ __ ] about the government and say
whatever she wants cuz she's like well
[ __ ] it what are gonna do take my money
away you already like that yeah I'm
gonna say whatever the [ __ ] I want
because I do feel like a lot of the
especially in the NFL are these athletes
they don't say [ __ ] cuz they're so
afraid they're gonna lose their job yeah
yeah you know well I think that like men
have to stick up for what I mean like
it's not taking any money away from them
so like when you know there are
commercials for for of like NBA players
talking about like you know you should
respect women's basketball players but
it's nothing to do with the money and
I'm like why I don't want to you guys
say like you should respect them by
paying me more because right a WNBA
player is paid like the highest paying
player is paid like a fourth of what
like the
the guy who has like two broken legs
right and the NBA the worst player right
wasn't with the I don't know anything
about sports but so like the guy with
the bags of money hands them to the
soccer team anything coins I also wanted
to talk about how a lot of times when
women and minorities we see potential
income you kind of go for it cuz there
was this gamer girl Belle Delphine she
was selling her bathwater for $30 online
and she like made a killing apparently
and people were like you know dragging
her but I'm like [ __ ] good for her
dudes and making it she's 19 years old
Wow yeah she's [ __ ] killing the game
if you asked me I wanna know what
happens to the bathwater so you get it
in the mail oh my god FedEx or whatever
and then like what and you probably
brought it on your dick I don't know
what men do with this heavy [ __ ] but I
assume it's something disgusting men are
gross gross gross but like that's why
you take advantage of them yeah Michael
it's why women can sell like pictures of
their feet to men I mean shout-out to
Becky feet calm for grading me okay
appreciate the shout out if you want to
ask the questions be answered here on
you welcome email you welcome questions
at gmail.com I was going through a rough
time financially and job wise in 2013 I
gave my dog to a co-worker and her
family whoo I didn't tell my friends
what was going on with me at the time
and lately they've been asking me where
my dog is because obviously I hadn't
posted any pictures ever recently I'm
sorry that's funny I'm just like I gave
away my dog and everyone's asking
because it's missing okay sorry sorry
I made up a story that my cousin her
husband have her as an emotional support
animal temporarily because her dog died
which is true I've actually asked me
coworker if I can get my dog back and
she told me I'm welcome to visit but
it's probably best she stays at a stable
home it was harsh
no that wasn't but I understand where
she's coming from I guess my question is
should I keep hiding us or my friends or
should I tell them the truth is it too
late because I already created the story
about my cousin having her Wow
okay I mean I think we all know the
answer to that question definitely tell
them the truth because I mean you know I
find it interesting how people are so
scared to admit to the people that are
closest to them that they're having a
hard time financially yeah you know and
I we've we just talked about it we've
all been there so I guess another waited
because the answer is obvious yes you
should tell them you should be very open
with them because it it's it's the truth
and it sucks but they should know and
and God bless your coworker for being
like no she's staying here because it's
more stable like that's a good person
that's why you chose her to have a dog I
guess it's like the stigma of poverty
really [ __ ] with people's heads that
they don't even want to like be open
about that [ __ ] but it's like I've got
my car for four years and I I mean I was
pretty open with all my friend I mean
people didn't know but my friends and my
family obviously knew because it was
like I just I needed help and it's it's
I I it's said that people have a hard
time asking for help and forming the
people closest to them that they're
having a hard time yeah yeah yeah yeah
completely yeah yeah because if you I
mean she could always lie and be like my
dog died and then but she'll think about
it like five years later she'll be like
man like she'll never be able she'll
always be in a lie she's I'm not gonna
funnel of lies right that's I guess
that's the other point of that is once
you start lying you do create yeah to
create more lies right all right next
question as a queer chick married to a
woman I've been unnerved by the news
that my sister-in-law is marrying one of
Mike Pence's nephews next year Wow juicy
yeah it's inevitable that I'm gonna be
introduced to him at this wedding
because he was at the engagement party
and I only managed to avoid meeting him
by literally running away great I love
that so in case I'm not able to park
Chloe from Park or away from him at the
wedding I love some help crafting the
perfect need to
Durer say that conveys my deep disdain
and disgust but like doesn't make a
scene people keep telling me to just
make out with my wife gratuitously the
whole time we're not big PDA types and I
wouldn't do that you've got the queerest
wedding that strategy doesn't work for
him anyways but la he's a piece of [ __ ]
people like Pence's whole thing is
perpetuating evil behind the flimsy veil
of good manners I guess more broadly
what do you think is a productive
approach for participating in an event
that involves a person that runs in
papal opposition to your entire human
existence
I turn to you oh my god well I could yes
but like we don't we don't know like is
sorry it's your family like help who
your family is so like is that it's his
nephew a dick like is this nephew also
home before bit crazy really just so I
like this yes why I picked this question
we all know my parents ISM yes [ __ ]
idiot and if he came for your wedding
you could tell me yeah I would punch him
in the face right right and call him
mother but I just is she saying that my
white pants isn't gonna be at the
wedding she's gonna be at the wedding
Mike Pence's or just a nephew yes Mike
Pence is gonna be at the wedding he was
at the engagement party oh okay oh then
I would punch my pants right I called
him mother oh my god I thought you're
gonna say mother [ __ ] and you're like
yeah that's what he likes yeah yeah that
is so interesting because I think if I
were in that situation I would never
have like I couldn't go up to him I
would just maybe like give him eyes but
like yeah I'm so used to that but I I
would go either way it depends on a
moment but I like fries and anger and
just not be able to do anything and have
to remove myself in the situation or I
might go crazy right Rach I'm in the
face yeah so what do you suggest that
this person does this woman I mean but
she's a guest at the wedding yeah I mean
she doesn't want to ruin someone's
wedding - I'm just like just I don't
exactly slip him a note
yeah also like do you have to ordered a
wedding right it's a wedding
yeah you can't miss some stale ass cake
well thank you to my guest mo Welch and
Nico's
Antos follow them on social media
they're both hilarious and see them live
when you can thank you so much for
tuning in you welcome [ __ ]
[Music]